- You got married!
I've been noticing that rock, Miss Thing.
(laughing)
You got married this Spring, right?
- I did, I got married in March.
- Yay! Are you still
in the honeymoon phase?
- You know, yeah, definitely.
I feel like we got
married and then went on
an awesome honeymoon,
and then I just jumped right into work.
So, I would definitely advise
any like, brides to be like,
give yourself like, a little
bit more time to like,
but it is still so nice.
I say husband so much it's obnoxious.
Like, literally.
- Oh, when we got married, my
husband and I, we literally,
we're so dorky, I was
so excited because I was
never married before and I was like,
"I'm changing your name
to husband in my phone."
- I did too!
(laughing and applause)
- I did!
- Except it's a "Husband" and
then I put a red heart emoji--
- Oh, I'm not as cute as you.
- So then when he calls it's like,
"Husband, red heart, husband, red heart."
- It says that?
- Yeah.
- That's amazing!
- Let's talk about music,
what are like, your
songs that inspire you?
- Oh my Gosh!
- Because you sing so many genres,
I do that as well, so I was just curious.
- But you know how hard that is, like,
I would say the first
song for me would be this
Castle on a Cloud which is
the song I sang in Les Mis.
Because I'd never sang before in my life,
and then I went for an
open call for Les Mis
in my hometown, sang that
song, and got the part
and was on Broadway two weeks later.
(applause and cheering)
- Hashtag blessed.
- It was kinda crazy.
- That's awesome!
- And then I've been working.
So, that song, I also love
anything on Jagged Little Pill,
that was the first record I ever bought.
- Yes, perfect! I love that song.
- And then, Don't Rain
on my Parade because--
- That's one of my favorites.
- Oh, really?
- I love Funny Girl.
- Oh, me too.
- It was my like, first movie musical.
- Get in line, Kelly, get in line!
- Yeah, I love it, I love Barbara, I do.
- And then, don't think
I'm like, just saying this,
but Since You've Been
Gone for me was like--
- Oh you're such a--
- I'm serious. Wait, well, what are yours?
- Mine, Why, Annie Lennox is
definitely one of my favorites.
- You have a lot of Annie Lennox stuff,
And then she gives a cute
little gift bag to everyone.
- A wine and vinyl.
It's my favorite thing.
- I love that.
- Yes, I love wine and
vinyl at the same time.
- Okay, Annie Lennox.
- So, Why, Annie Lennox.
I'd probably say Bonnie
Raitt, Love Me Like a Man.
Woo!
And I'm talking about the live version,
the record version's all right,
the live version is a jam.
And then I'd say I've Never
Loved a Man, by Aretha Franklin.
- Oh yeah.
- But, I feel like I also do like men.
(laughter)
I don't know why I picked just women.
- Well, I picked all girls.
I love female singers.
- Well, we're female
singers, so that's why.
- But I do, I really do.
Everyone's like, "What do you listen to?
"What kind of music do you like?"
I'm like, "Any girls,
like any girl singers."
- I don't want any girl,
I want powerful women.
- Well yeah, but I'm into
like, it could be country--
- It's sexy!
it could be pop, it could
be any female vocalist,
I'm just like, give it to me.
They're my favorite.
- Yes, I'm the same.
- Sorry boys.
(laughter)
- All right, so, tell
us about your new album,
your Christmas project.
- Yeah, it's my first Christmas record,
it's coming out, it's called
Christmas in the City.
And for me--
(applause and cheering)
- Oh yeah, there it is!
- Look at that dress!
- Thank you. I'm from New York,
born and raised in the city,
and I moved out here 10 years ago,
and the one thing I've really
missed are my Christmases
in New York.
And I go home every holiday--
- It's beautiful.
- But it's the best,
and so this is all about
that time of year that
reminds me of family,
and being with friends,
and being where I was,
you know, born and raised,
and I just picked all of my
favorite Christmas songs.
It was just amazing.